I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Oh, hi.
Lady, I have a new way I'm being influenced.
I'm being influenced into making my bed a very specific way.
Like different than how you've been.
made it your whole life? Different than how I've been making it. Yeah, I like a made bed because at night
I like to get into a bed that's made. Listen, I like a made bed because then I feel like my room doesn't
feel cluttered. Same. I can have maybe like a pile of clothes I need to put away, but if my bed is made,
I don't feel so, you know, sloppy. Same. Well, I got influenced. I saw this video, this guy making
his bed. He's very certain about how it should be made. Okay. And I love it so much that.
I'm making my kids' beds again.
I'm making all the beds.
I make beds like on the weekends.
Like on a week morning, everyone's like running out.
I'm like, ah.
No, I'm so excited to make beds now.
Can I ask, how were you influenced to make your bed differently?
I'll share the video with you.
I would love it.
I'll share it with everyone.
I'm huge into making my bed.
He's delightful.
So first of all, I would always sort of pull the comforter all the way up and then put the
pillows on top of it.
That's like a hard no for him.
He's like, no.
You bend back the comforter to let the sheets breathe underneath.
And then also you don't put your pillows vertical.
You put them horizontal.
Like a hotel.
Yes.
It kind of is like a hotel bed.
And he has strong feelings about throw pillows.
I bet he doesn't like them because he wants all the pillows flat.
I bet there's no throw pillows on his bed.
You can have one long lumbar pillow sitting in front of your four stacked pillows, the end.
So my two hummingbird pillows are off the bed, huh?
I mean...
They didn't make the cut.
Wow.
Sorry.
Well, you know what, fella?
You don't get to tell me.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my goodness.
Don't come between me and my hummingbird pillows that my mom got at Cracker Barrel.
Well, I want to share with everyone that you had a little bit of a Pam moment this week at work.
What?
Oh, no.
You're going to tell people about that?
Sam.
Um, go, go nuts.
Did someone in this office make a sign and hung it over the sink?
It is eerily similar to the sign of the show.
This one might be more passive aggressive.
So Jenna got here before me.
I come in and she's just like writing something and then she's taping it.
And I'm like, what is happening?
And Sam's like, well, go read the sign.
Sam, will you read it?
It says, please wash your own dishes.
Dishwashing service is not provided here.
Because we share this space.
Yes, we do.
With other podcasts and people recording things.
And I keep coming in and the sink is just full of people's dirty cups and dishes.
And we should say, you guys, at the end of our recording day, we clean anything in the sink that was ours.
And we clean the studio.
Yeah.
We tidy up.
Well, I think there's some new people recording here.
We don't know who they are.
It's not Ben Stiller and Adam Scott.
I want to say there were never dishes in the sink.
when they were here. Yeah, really big headset settings, but no dishes. But whoever has been coming in,
I think they might have assumed that maybe that's part of the custodial service. And you're letting
them know. I'm letting them know. It is not. I'm tired of washing your shit. I'm going to take a
picture of you by it. Can I give you a quick update on the situation? Sure. Yeah, Matt.
So I've let our landlords and people who manage the building know about the situation. And there's a
full-on investigation.
Stop it.
Possibly involving security footage of who might be there.
There's an investigation underway.
Oh, my, Matt.
I need closure on this now.
Into who is leaving the dishes in the sink?
This is your first mom detective case with an actual result.
This is not yet.
Not yet.
True.
Wow.
Wait, so now I'm so baffled.
Are there cameras in our kitchen?
I think just in the building hall,
ways.
Oh.
Not that, I mean, you guys, I haven't done anything in the kitchen.
I'm just saying, well, we did change clothes in there.
We have changed clothes in the offices here.
I know.
Like, you'll have a meeting and we'll change clothes before we, like, hop on the Zoom.
Exactly.
Building security footage.
Okay, good.
So, okay, this is interesting.
So they are looking at the date of the dirty dishes from probably last week when I was annoyed.
and I sent something.
Who was in the hallway and who went in.
They are.
We got our best people on it.
Wow.
I had no idea.
I just thought, Matt, you just fired off a snarky email like, hey, clean your tissues.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
Well, yeah.
Okay, so, Jenna, you have a tidy bed and we're going to have a tidy office.
Where are we?
That was a lot of banter.
It was.
Up top, but we're in a bantering mood.
We have a really fun episode today, though.
With a great guest.
Yes.
we got to interview Robin Lynch, who played the CPR instructor in Stress Relief Part 1.
So in our original breakdown of the episode, we had shared that we tried to get a hold of her
and we wanted to speak with her. Well, after that episode aired, we got a message from Robin
thanking us for our kind words about her performance. And she was like, I would love to come
and share about my experience on the show. So listen, this was a really fun chat. She is such a
lovely person. You might remember that I suspected she had some sort of actual CPR experience because
she was so real. And in our interview, Robin will reveal if I was right. But first, we have our
chit-chat suggestion from Leanne P in Cleveland, Ohio. Hi, office ladies. My name is Leanne and I'm
from Cleveland, Ohio. I am a history buff and often wonder what it would have been like to
witness certain events. This is especially true when I visit the Gettysburg battlefield.
My chit-chat question is this.
If you could be a fly on the wall and witness any event in history, what would you choose?
It could be a major event or something small that has always fascinated you.
Looking forward to your answer.
Did you have something come to mind right away?
I had something that came to my mind immediately.
Like two things actually.
Okay.
Can I share both?
Of course.
Okay.
So the first one, you guys, is years ago, I was in London and I did a tour of the Hampton Court
Palace. And on this tour, I was not expecting this. I sort of thought I would see like old rooms and,
you know, like ye oldy things. We turn this corner and we enter into what looks like a very small
tennis court. Oh, I've seen it. I've been there. Yes, right? It's indoors. It's indoors. It was built
in the 1520s. I guess it still remains active today and you can play on it if you remember.
There were two guys playing tennis.
When you were there?
Yes.
Oh, no one was playing when I was there.
Well, anyway, I guess the history says that Henry the 8th was an avid and very skilled player of what they called real tennis, which was often called the Sport of Kings.
It was the precursor to what we know now as modern tennis.
And I just would love to just be a fly on the wall watching Henry the 8th in his whatever, his whole royal court playing this game.
that would be fascinating to me.
Very cool.
Right?
So obviously that's driven by my love of tennis and just wanting to see what that game looked like in the 1520s.
But then the other thing I've always sort of, I don't know if the word romanticize is right,
but I've just always thought it would have been so cool to witness the very first moon landing
and walking on the moon.
Like, I can't imagine the electricity
that was going through our country at that time
and the excitement and how collectively
everyone came together to watch and witness this moment.
You know, people gathered around their televisions
and the feeling that felt like
to see that moment in history,
I think would be so amazing to see in real time.
You know, you can see old footage of it,
but to be at home with your family,
watching your little home TV of that event must have just been so amazing.
Yeah.
So those were the two that came to mind.
I mean, you know, there's so many.
It's hard to pick, you know, but Leanne, I loved this question.
Well, it's interesting.
I thought about the moon landing as well.
Did you really?
I did because I thought how there are some things that when they're happening,
you know they are historic, and that's an example of one.
Yes.
And then there's other things that only,
later, you realize.
You sort of realize, oh, that was a historic moment.
But if you were there, it might not feel any different than just a regular moment.
But I got really caught up.
Like my first thought was that I thought of all like the unsolved crimes.
And I thought, oh, what if I could be there to see what really happened?
And then I would just know.
Like I could just, not that I want to see a crime.
Oh, my goodness.
But, you know, like, then we'd have, like, certainty.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
Yeah.
But then I don't really want to see a crime happen because that feels disturbing and upsetting.
You don't want to see the crime.
You want to see who did it.
Yeah.
I want to end the mystery.
Like whoever's leaving the, you're like, ah, it was you.
We knew it.
And we were right all along.
Or like, oh, my gosh, they really were innocent or whatever.
Or mystery solved.
This is very much your brain of, like,
Your brain likes to finish an equation, solve a problem, put that last piece in the puzzle.
I guess I thought, like, I did think, how could it be useful to more than just myself?
Mom detectives of history.
Oh.
I guess so.
We go back and solve all the crimes of the past.
Yes, with snacks.
You could go back to two weeks ago and see who was in our kitchen.
Ah, yes.
Exactly.
But then I was like, okay, since I don't really want to witness an actual crime that feels upsetting, I googled.
I was a lady who Googles.
And I was like, what are some historical events that would be cool to witness?
It's literally what I put in.
And you know what popped up that I was like, yeah?
And it's a little bit in the same vein is the construction of the pyramids.
Oh, yes.
Because like, wouldn't you like to be like, that's how they did it?
Yeah.
Well, aliens.
Well, I could answer that question for you because I will have seen it.
Sam, what about you?
I, okay, my brain went to where your brain went.
It went to like Black Dahlia or Jack the Ripper.
But in the same thing, I don't want to see those murders happen.
So I landed on, do you guys know who D.B. Cooper is?
I did not.
D.B. Cooper was the alias that he gave to the FBI.
So in November 24, 1971, a guy named D.B. Cooper hijacked a Northwest Orient flight,
demanded a $200,000 ransom and parachuted from the plane into a heavily wooded area of South Washington.
Experts highly doubt he survived the freezing temperatures and high-speed winds, but in 1980,
a young boy discovered a decaying package containing $5,800 of the ransom money buried along the
Columbia River.
So I would just be curious who that guy was.
Like, where if he made it?
Did he make it or did someone find his dead body and the money?
Exactly.
Or did he leave some of the money out so that?
that he would appear dead.
Oh.
Yeah.
You guys both want a mom detective history.
I think I just want to time travel is what I want to use this for.
I want to time travel and play tennis.
Yeah.
Also,
I'm laughing so hard at the idea of you backhanding,
was it King Henry the 8th in the face,
but you hulking out on a living king.
Oh, my gosh.
I would be sent to the tower.
Yeah, exactly.
A little angela.
Yeah.
If I could beheaded afterwards.
I know.
I'd be like, sorry.
Yeah.
You shouldn't have been in the way.
Do you do your racket up, Henry the 8th?
Leg kick.
It's too funny.
Matt, what about you?
Do you have one?
Yeah, so I love American history.
So, like, kind of my first thoughts are, like, something kind of rugged.
Like, I've always loved the Revolutionary War or, like, the Gold Rush.
But then I sort of think, like, it sounds kind of, like, hard and cold, and, like, most people
aren't brushing their teeth at that time and just, like, sounds a little too rugged for me.
The Gold Rush is too rugged.
Yeah, I kind of just want to go to a swing in good time, like Paris before the war or the summer of love or something like that.
Oh, yeah.
You know, I'm just here for the vibes.
Oh, my God.
If I could be at the Green Day concert with the mud fight, that would be like so epic.
Yeah, those would suck 94.
Yeah.
Or like I think about too that that amazing concert with Queen.
Was it Live Aid where it was that massive stadium?
That just felt like election.
electric, didn't it? Yeah. Yeah. That was another one where everyone, no matter where you were,
was at your TV set, like the moon landing. Yeah, yeah. I mean, partially for me, for the moon landing.
Okay, cool, science, yay. But also, you know, I'd have a really cute outfit. Yeah. And along those
same vines, I'll say Beatles playing Ed Sullivan would be pretty... Oh, that'd be amazing. Their first time in
America would be pretty great. All right. Yay. Yay. So fun. Well, we're going to solve some mysteries and have
some fun, listen to music and play tennis when we go back in time. Thank you so much.
Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we are going to talk about a few of
the extra things that were added back to Stress Relief Part 1 from the Superfan episode. And
we are going to talk with Robin Lynch, who played Rose, the CPR instructor.
And you all know that the CPR training from Season 5 Stress Relief Part 1, it's epic. We all know this
scene. It's after Dwight's crazy fire drill, Stanley collapses, and now Michael is called everyone
into the conference room to get CPR training. Should Stanley's heart, quote, go berserk again?
Every time Michael said Stanley's heart, well, it went berserk. It makes me laugh. So the superfan
version of this episode is fantastic. Way to go. Dave Rogers. And there's a ton of extra stuff
just from the CPR scenes that was put back in. For example, the moment we first meet Rose,
in the conference room is much longer,
and she and Michael will really get into it right from the beginning.
Rose kind of makes a joke and people laugh a little,
and Michael does not like it.
He never likes that.
Let's hear it.
ABC, okay?
And that stands for airway, breathing, and circulation.
Okay, you know what, that could be a little confusing
because in sales, ABC means always be closing.
Well, try not to close the sale when administering CPR.
Okay, well, um,
Rose is it? This is serious and you're sort of making a mockery of it. We almost lost one of our employees and I feel like you're being a little jerky and a little condescending and sort of a tool.
Okay, I'm here to do a job and you cannot talk to me that way.
Well, honestly, the only reason that you are here, Rose, is because I couldn't get a CPR dummy.
So if you want to wander around for an hour, that's...
This is a farce. I should be teaching this course. Shut it, shut it.
Yeah, so Michael then has this talking head where he explains, like, he tried to get a CPR dummy by itself, but they insist that an instructor come with it. It's so amazing. But I love Rose, is it?
I also love, you know what, and you're kind of being a tool.
Can you imagine someone saying that to you if you've just like come to do this demonstration at an office? It's crazy.
So next up, we see Kevin, and he's administering chest compressions to the dummy.
But in the superfan version, there's more bickering between Michael and Rose and Dwight gets in on it, too.
You have to hear it.
Rose, I am sorry.
It is just that Stanley Hudson here almost died.
We almost lost him.
And we need you to take this very seriously.
I am taking this seriously.
All right.
Well, then no more jokes, please.
Anyway, the first thing you need to do is assess the situation.
You can ask, are you okay?
Really?
He's had a heart attack, and you're going to make idle chit-chat?
Are you even certified?
Shut it, Dwight.
Okay.
So there you go.
She has her hands full with these guys.
For sure.
And it's only going to get worse.
So now we have this bit where Michael is trying to convince Stanley to try administering CPR to the dummy.
And Stanley is not interested.
And this is when Michael has that great line where he says,
we're not always going to be there to coddle your heart back
when it disappears to be working.
What are you going to do if you are by yourself and your heart stops?
And Stanley says, I would die.
And Michael says, and you're okay with that?
And Stanley says, I'm okay with the logic of it.
I've always loved that exchange.
Me too.
Such a great scene.
And Leslie, like, his delivery is perfect.
Well, lady, when I was rewatching it, this whole exchange, it happens in front of Andy, Oscar, Phyllis, and Meredith.
They are like lined up in chairs along the wall. Michael is on his knees in front of Stanley in the wheelchair.
And I just have to encourage people to watch those four actors in the background during this exchange.
It is such an amazing, just deadpan, active listening work that they are doing.
nobody steals focus, but everyone is completely dialed in, engaged.
They're in character.
I think it's a top tier background acting moment on the show.
I'm for sure going to check it out because I remember desperately wanting to be on the back row
and they put me right in the front.
And I'm almost never in the front.
And I was like, today of all days, where this is happening right there, I'm in the front.
I was like, oh, no, I was so.
worried I was going to break. Okay, well, so Michael does end up convincing Stanley to try CPR,
but he's going to bail pretty quickly. And Michael has to take over. And Rose says, okay,
assessing the situation, are they breathing? And Michael says, no, Rose, they are not breathing,
but Steve is Michael says it's so snarky. So snarky. And then he says, and they have no arms or
legs. And Rose replies, that's not part of it.
So this obsession with what happened to the dummies, arms, and legs is much longer in the superfan version.
Like Michael and Dwight get very preoccupied with also like, what is the location of this person?
Where were they found?
And, you know, Rose is trying to be like, you're in an office, but it goes all over the place.
You have to hear it.
You know what?
If we come across somebody with no arms or legs, do we bother resuscitating them?
I mean, what kind of quality of life do we have there?
I would want to live with no legs.
How about no arms?
No arms or legs is basically how you exist right now, Kevin.
You don't do anything.
Here's another question.
Was he born this way with no arms or legs?
Or were they blown off?
If that's the case, should we use a tourniquet to tie off the bloody stumps?
Okay, we're not going to be covering turnicets today just because that rarely happens in an office place?
Not covering turniquets?
That should be the first thing we cover.
Otherwise, the blood will just go.
oozing out of the stumps.
I think Dwight is right.
Okay, this is the scenario.
This is a battlefield and there are bodies all over the place and some have had heart
attacks and other people are just resting.
So I think in that case, to go up to someone and say, are you okay?
That makes sense to me.
Okay, for the sake of argument, we are now at a battlefield and I think it's okay to
ask somebody if that's okay even in an office.
And now who would like to come up and care for the job?
You know what, I'm already here.
I'll do it.
Okay.
So I'm walking across the battlefield.
There's someone.
Are they a heart attack victim or are they resting?
Are you okay?
Oh my God!
Your arms and legs have been blown off.
I mean, it's just he can't focus.
He can't.
It's not about CPR at all now.
He's like reenacting some battlefield moment.
I really don't know how Robin got through it.
Also, you know, just being on set for the first time and now you're in front of the whole
entire group and she's driving the scene. It's just amazing. And so ultimately, this training ends
with Rose suggesting that Michael do chest compressions to the tune of staying alive.
And this quickly turns into a full-on dance party. Yes, the whole scene is amazing. It's so funny.
I think it's time that we talk to Robin about it. So here is the interview we had with Robin Lynch,
who plays Rose, the CPR instructor.
Hey, guys. Office ladies.
we're so happy to have you here.
Oh, you look just the same.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
So do you guys.
I feel like nothing.
Time has not changed, my friends.
Everything is good.
We're so excited that you're joining us today.
We have been, you know, we rewatched every episode of the show, but we've been revisiting
them every Monday.
And oh my gosh, we found all this extra footage from your CPR scenes and the superfan.
Have you seen it?
I honestly just watched it the other night.
So all this time has gone by, and I have only seen what everyone else saw on that original
airing. So I sat there. I'm watching it. I'm like, oh, yeah, I totally forgot. I forgot about all those
extra lines and that interaction with the cast with Steve Corrello. It was brilliant. I sat there.
I was like, and all I thought was my skin looks great.
That was my takeaway. You look fantastic.
Well, you know what? We were thrilled to watch the scenes, too, and we were cracking up.
thank you for being here today.
We're going to kick this off with this question.
How did you get your role as Rose, the CPR instructor on the office?
Because you know, I wondered if you were a real CPR.
You were convinced.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That is, on a side note, when you talked about that in the podcast about stress relief,
I think it was like two years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
I was getting my carpet steamed.
Oh.
And my CPA called me.
And he's like, Robin, the girls are talking about you about your office episode.
They thought you were a real nurse.
And I'm like, I thought it was a real.
Like, I had no idea that was happening.
So, of course, I immediately listened and cried because I was like, oh, my gosh, that's like the biggest compliment.
An actor can ever hear that they actually, someone actually thinks that that's what they're, who they really are.
Yes.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Cried like a baby.
You definitely nailed the realism.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it didn't matter how crazy the room got.
it was like, I'm just here to do this job and I'm trying my best to do it.
And that's not easy to do when you have a bunch of wackadoos all around you.
Well, that was the bottom line is when I got the script.
And I knew the show.
So that was important.
So what happened was my agent reached out to me, who by the way, I never actually met this agent in person.
It was one of those online agents like you get them online through actors access or whatever.
So he had never seen me in person.
And when he sent me on the audition, the description was a 60, 60, 6.0.
year old, six zero, six zero year old and draconous woman.
So I get, I get the breakdown.
I'm like, I know this guy hasn't seen me before, but okay, whatever.
So I, you know, I go to the audition and it's Allison Jones casting.
And is it okay if I ask you how old you were as opposed to not being 60?
Oh, 35.
Okay.
No, 35.
So I'm like, okay, cool.
So I go, I'm waiting with these lovely women that were of that age.
Okay.
And I'm just sitting there like, I don't know what's going to happen.
I'm just happy to be here.
Happy to be here.
But I remember the direction that Ben Harris gave me, which was, he's like, just don't act.
Just don't.
It's okay.
And that's what we did.
And that was like, and you knew the show.
So you knew sort of the tone of it.
I knew the show and I knew that y'all didn't want me to sing it.
It was more me going to use it to teach CPR.
So that's what I did.
And I just kept it simple.
And we, and I didn't have.
a lot of time really to overanalyze things because I was on set the very next day.
Wow.
You were in the audition room the day prior?
Yes.
So I 15 pages of dialogue.
And I was like, all right.
15 pages for the audition?
Oh my goodness.
And you had to be off books.
So I'm like, okay, let's go.
And we just had so much fun.
And it was, I left and it was so nice.
Ben was like, nice working with you.
And I was like, I'm like, yay.
And so for me, I had.
already won. I was like, I went in there, did my thing, Ben was cool. I'm like, awesome. And then
an hour later they called and said, we need you on set tomorrow at 12th. And I was like,
an hour later. An hour later on my flip bone. Those were the days. Those are the days when you're
driving with your flip on. I was like, okay, so I just got home, ran over the lines. And the next morning,
I worked out. And I just didn't have time to freak out. And I just got to set when I got there,
Angela, I think I was wearing a pair of your pants.
They couldn't find anything for me to wear.
I was wearing my purple jacket.
I wore that.
That's mine.
But they just kept layering me.
Because when I watched the episode the other day, I was like, God, it looked like a
habit.
I looked so small.
So they kept like putting all these layers on me, I think, to make me look like a human,
which is great.
And off we went.
And I remember we did one rehearsal.
And again, Jeffrey Blitz was great.
He just came over and said, don't act.
Just do it.
And we just did it.
You just did it.
And they were throwing you curveballs left and right.
They were so funny.
Ed Helms, that little rascal, he was trying to make me laugh the whole time.
He almost got me.
He almost did.
When we rewatch the super fan, he does this thing where he hip checks you.
Like he turns while he's dancing and kind of like hits you with his tush.
And you kind of bump.
And you're like, what is happening?
That's exactly.
My face, I was just like, don't laugh.
go do it. And then, you know, I remember Mindy is up there, Dan, I was just like, and remember,
I didn't know anything about the episode. I didn't get your script. I only got my part. So when I showed
up, oh, that's interesting. I had no idea what was going on. I heard you guys talking about a cat
falling. And I remember being very like, do they throw animals? What was going on? I'm like,
I'm like, whatever. And I was in my lane. I'm like, okay, just, okay, where am I stand here? And then,
And as I watched it the other day, I'm like, oh, I see why they did how they actually had Steve, like, leaning over and everyone was sitting in chairs.
I'm so short that they had to kind of work with the height and have the cast.
And it was like, oh, that's brilliant.
That really worked great.
Was that, like, dancing part of it?
Was that the hardest to keep a straight face?
Oh, I would say the entire thing.
I mean, literally, yeah.
That was the hardest part.
But when Creed says his line, that was a moment Steve and I had with him.
We're like, what, what are you saying?
What's happening?
And I'm just like, you can see, if you really look, you can see me.
Whenever I puckered, I'm like, don't do it.
Also, Steve is Michael in the extended scenes.
He really goes at Rose.
He's like, you know what, Rose?
Do your job.
Like, he gets very antagonistic with you.
Yeah.
I know.
I've forgotten all of that.
So when I was watching it, I'm like, oh, that's so funny.
But Rose, I mean, it's my character.
She just kind of kept telling that line.
Kept it moving, kept it going.
I wonder like, what stories did Rose tell her friend and significant other when she left
that office that day, right?
Like, you guys are not going to believe what happened to the day.
I'm pretty sure Rose changed careers.
In my mind, Rose, like, forget this.
I'm going to go to HR.
I'm going to be, I'm going to go work with trees.
I'm done.
Like, you can tell she was at the end of her rope.
Yeah, we broke Rose, unfortunately.
Basically, I think you did.
When Dwight stabbed the CPR tummy, that was pretty much it for Rose.
We are so curious if you have like a favorite memory from being on set or any kind of behind the scenes thing that you hold dear.
Well, I would say for you, Miss Angela, you were just so kind.
I remember that you made sure I had clothes.
You told me where to put the clothes at the end.
It was like 11 at night.
I'm like, where do I put my war?
everyone was gone.
I'm like, where do I put my wardrobe?
And you're like, just leave it in your trailer.
And I remember leaving and just being like, that is so nice.
I felt like I could go out with you guys afterwards.
It was just a warm set.
Everyone was lovely.
And I felt like a receiving line at the end of everyone was like shaking my hand.
And I was, you know, I'm just like, I honestly, when I went to set, kind of was like,
oh, you know, they're going to probably cut some of these lines.
It's a lot of lines.
And I, you know, and I was convinced, I still am convinced that I mean,
may have replaced them the last minute.
We are not aware of that.
That is a story I tell myself all the time because it was such a quick cast.
We move pretty fast sometimes, though.
So I would say toot your own horn, lady.
I think that part was yours all along.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I definitely felt like when I was on set, even watching it the other day, I was like,
oh, yeah, I was supposed to be there.
That's a night.
It was such a nice feeling.
So having those wonderful feelings are kind of what I take away from the office.
And it was surreal for me to be looking.
Like when Steve Carrell was like, hi, I'm Steve Carrell.
I'm like, in my head.
There's like a squirrel in my head being like,
Steve Carrella is walking up to you.
Steve Corrella was putting out his ear.
Steve Carrella said hello to you.
Steve Carell is really in shape.
I'm like, wow, he's really in shape.
I mean, this is what was going on in my head.
And then I'm just like, keep it together.
Rain Wilson kept trying to give me high fives.
I could not reach.
He kept doing that.
I was like, dude, I can't reach.
And then someone did ask.
I think it was, I think it was Rain or Ed said, hey, are you a nurse? I'm like, no.
Well, where does this role rank in terms of film and television appearances for you?
Because you're saying this was a new agent. This was someone who you hadn't even met in person.
And now you go out and you book this role.
Huge. It was completely huge. You know, one of the things I did when I moved to L.A.
after college as I went and worked in a casting office for a few months, just an internship.
And it was one of the best things I ever did as an actor because I really could watch how a part meets a person.
It's a serendipity.
It's this magic thing.
It's their part.
And years later, when I'm auditioning and I'm, you know, I'm in the hustle.
I'm just trying to meet people, you know, get as much experience as possible.
When it happened to me, like emotionally spiritual, everything, I was like, oh, it is true.
It does happen, you know, to have that actually happen.
And as far as credits, huge, huge credits.
the biggest push, obviously when the Super Bowl aired and we watched it, it was the first hour-long
episode and won an Emmy.
Yeah.
So this is a no-joke episode.
So thrilled, so thankful to be part of that.
But when Netflix put it on the network during the pandemic area, like era, that then gave me a new audience.
And not only did I have the parents that watched the office at their kids.
So that's another reason why, you know, I waited tables forever.
So I would wait on people and people say, hey, aren't you Rosa CPRN's director?
I'm like, yeah, I am.
How are you?
And in fact, I was getting a facial yesterday and my facialist said, aren't you roses?
I mean, it's crazy.
So that is the strongest movement.
When you look at other pieces of work, like projects that I have developed or been in that
have other special meetings, but this one is really special.
And I knew it when I was on set.
I'm like, this is something special is going to happen here.
So.
Was it wild to see that?
after the Super Bowl.
Like as you're sitting there,
like if you go back in time,
like take me back to like you're sitting on your couch
and you know you have the Super Bowl audience.
Well, we learned something that night.
First of all, if you're in a big episode of a show,
don't invite everybody over.
What?
I invited like a ton of people.
I had like a party at my house.
At that time, I was married.
So my husband was there and his friends.
It was like a gorgeous little party.
And I was so nervous.
I was like, I don't know how this is going to go.
I mean, this could be awful.
Because you haven't seen it yet, right?
You haven't pre-screened it.
You don't know.
I had no idea.
And I was like, I will never do that again.
I will just let you know when it's airing and good luck with that because it was too stressful.
So when I watched it, I was, it was nervous the whole time.
And then I was like, oh, yeah, I did that.
Okay, good.
Again, I knew something special.
When the Emmys were happening, I was, this time I was by myself.
And, you know, I'm just like, I'm not going to risk that again.
And I was like, and I didn't even know the episode was up.
for an Emmy. I was just like, I'm going to watch the Emmys. See what happens. And I was like,
that's the episode. It's so fantastic. So it was, again, for me, I always tell folks,
it's the gift that keeps given. It just keeps given. Yeah. Like, even today, it's so lovely to see
you guys. It's so wonderful to talk about work that means a lot, not just to me, but when I,
I get recognized, people are thrilled. They're not, they're just, it makes them so happy,
brings so much joy. Like, to be a part of that, I'm, I feel. I feel.
like the luckiest girl in the world.
Well, you're a huge part of that.
I mean, there's many episodes, obviously, that are fan favorites,
but this is one of the big tent pole episodes.
And I love that people just come up and share their joy with you,
because that's how we feel, too.
Everyone's so nice.
Yeah.
And your fan base is lovely.
And what you're doing with the show is so lovely.
And I hope you guys know that.
It's like, I don't know if people tell you enough that what you're building is this wonderful,
warm community of positivity when you talk to your fans and answer their questions.
And listening, I listen to your podcast and I feel like I'm talking like you're in my car
with me.
Like they're not in there, even how you talk about your products like the advertisement,
the way that you describe.
I'm just like, oh my gosh, totally gets that.
Okay, I get it.
It's such a breakthrough with your stuff.
We did win an award for our ad reads.
Oh, yeah, you did.
We were super excited.
We were proud of that.
You know, that's.
It's like, this show is free and it's paid for by advertising, but we're like, they don't need to be boring to listen to.
So thank you for that compliment.
Yeah.
You're so welcome.
Well, Robin, what are you working on right now?
Is there anything we can shout out to our listeners?
Sure.
Thank you for asking.
So this has been a really fun year.
I've been pivoting from an actor, but also writer-performer.
So I just completed my first pilot for a comedy.
It's actually a drama.
It's a drominy disguised as a comedy.
Okay.
I like this thing. Last year was an interesting year for me. I had multiple jobs. You know,
after COVID and the strikes, you know, we had the union strikes. It was, it's been a bit crazy
out here in L.A. So I ended up having a few jobs. And one of the jobs that I had, I worked at a medical
device company here in Los Angeles. And it's a call center. And I remember walking and saying,
oh my God, this is a show. So I wrote my first pilot about that in Pitch Check and Treatment. So now I'm
sharing it and getting feedback.
And it's called On the Line.
And the fun part about this show and the experience that I had was this office is like
still in 1982.
And they're dealing with people with medical devices that work.
The device is great.
But how they run the joint is like from the 80s.
And I remember just sitting there going and the characters that it was the ensemble cast.
It was brilliant.
I'm like, this is so rich.
I stayed there for three months and did like recon.
I just like pulled, pulled, pulled, and then I sat and I wrote.
And I'm like, being an actor has been wonderful, but be able to transition to writing as well.
I feel very thankful.
It's like opening up a whole new world for me.
So that's what I'm working on right now.
It's very exciting.
That's wonderful.
Yeah, you'll have to update us as things go because that's so exciting.
I'll let you know.
Aw, this was so great.
Thank you for spending this time with us and going over these scenes.
And like Angela said, this episode is just really.
beloved, but these scenes are really beloved. And it's one of the most memorable parts of the whole
series as this CPR training day. Rain says he gets that, he gets a lot of memes of himself.
We all do, right? Like they show up. But the one where he's cut the face off the dummy.
Yep. And everyone is screaming at him. And also all the real lives that have been saved
from people who remember the stay-in-alive advice.
Yes.
Do people share that with you?
So what happens, you know, I am a little, you know, a funny person.
I'm always making little jokes, but I was like, you know, we're actors.
We're not like saving lives.
But then I started getting articles from people around the country saying they used it to save like someone in Arizona used it.
A woman saved a squirrel with it.
And I'm like, we are saving lives.
I mean, that's actually happening with that song.
And I thought that was very, very sweet.
But people do share that with me often.
It's crazy that this,
culturally, everyone knows about this scene and about this song.
So it's pretty cool.
Really cool.
In rewatching it, I forgot how much Michael, like, came alive when,
I think it was the first thing Rose said that made any sense or was any fun to him
when Rose is like, actually, do you know staying alive by the Bee Gees?
He's like, I do.
He was so, he was like, Rose and I are about to jam.
So great.
And then he got the song wrong.
It was so great.
You started at the wrong spot and you're like, no, it's this part.
The course.
Yeah.
No, it was actually the wrong song.
That was, I will.
He was singing, I will survive.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Yes, yes, you're right.
Which is actually so perfect.
Well, is there anything from your time on the show or anything that you wanted to share that
we missed. Just again, so surreal, so quick. When I got there, they were just trying to put clothes on me.
I don't even think they put makeup on me. They were like, let's get her dressed. And off to the set,
we went. And I had, it was, you know, shot in Van Eyes. I had never been to Van Nuys before.
I was living on the west side. So I remember being like, wow, this is the valley.
Now I live out here. So I'm like, oh, yeah, it's right down the street. But I just remember in the
parking lot when I got there in my little corolla, I pull up my corolla. And Creed actually said,
I know you. He actually gave me the line in the parking lot before we even started. And I do see him,
by the way, at our Ralphs. Like I live right here where the Ralphs is. And like, I've seen him at Petco.
And he doesn't have a pet. And I'm like, what you doing here? He's like, I don't know. My grandfather,
my granddaughter. His daughter, yeah, has a dog. Yeah. It's so funny. But I just, again, I feel so
blessed that I got to work with you guys and have this experience and bring Rose to life. And yeah,
poor Rose after that, she definitely got a new job.
She quit.
She went on holiday for two weeks and never came back.
I'm out of here.
But yeah, so it was just a wonderful experience.
And everyone was so kind.
So thank you.
And thank you for having me on today just to connect.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, it took us so long to connect,
but I'm so glad we finally did.
Yeah, thank you for reaching out.
Yeah.
Of course.
My pleasure.
And I'll keep you guys posted when on the line gets a little traction.
Yeah.
We'd love it.
Oh, cool.
All right.
Take care, Robin.
Thanks, Robin.
Bye.
Well, that was just lovely.
Once again, it just brings me so much happiness to get to reconnect with people who are on the show.
And I love hearing how even just this one-day role has impacted her life 20 years later.
It's really cool.
And you guys, if you want to find Robin on Cameo, we'll be sharing that link in our stories.
So go and check it out.
All right.
Well, why don't we take a break?
And then we'll be back with Around the Town and our office question of the week.
I'm going to kick us off with an Around the Town.
from our snail mail. This is from Sam K from the United Kingdom. Sam said,
Dear Office ladies, I just wanted to say a genuine thank you for the office in your podcast.
Both the show and the podcast have been a constant companion for me while I'm working.
I spend a lot of time making miniatures at home and prop making. And having something comforting,
funny, and familiar on as I make makes such a difference. What I especially love is when you talk about
props and behind the scenes details. Prop making can often feel like a bit of an inside,
invisible craft in filmmaking. Hearing you highlight that side of things feels really special and
appreciated. Thank you again. Lots of love, Sam Kay. P.S., I hope the gifts arrived okay.
What are the gifts? Lady, he makes miniatures. Stop it. I know. You know, miniatures are my favorite
thing. I know. Is this a miniature? Is that what this box is? That top box, you have to open it. I'm going to
chairman stories. Isn't it amazing? Oh my God. This is, I could actually cry. It's so beautiful.
We have to describe to everyone. Okay, I have a shadow box with miniatures inside of it, and it is,
it's very Pam-centered, but also office-centered. So I have a little ream of Dundermifflin paper.
There's a little mixed berries yogurt. There is a teapot, a tiny,
teapot with also all the little things that were in the teapot. There is a yogurt lid. I don't even
understand how he made these itty-bitty paper clips. There's an itty-bitty the adventures of Jimmy
Helpert and some little shoes and Pam's watercolor. I mean, I... It's really...
Oh my gosh, and my mug, my pink mug! I know. It's really so special, Sam. I have a lot of the
similar things Jenna had that are office-centric, but I also have the babies playing jazz poster.
Oh my gosh, you have your Birkenstocks that you were bumping.
Yes, I have Angela and Dwight's Berkenstocks. I have, I have sprinkles collar. I have the little
cherub angel that Dwight keeps after they break up. I have the key that Angela gives Dwight
and, and Dwight's bobblehead. I have the little cat ears. I wore it Halloween. But then in the
middle, I have a baseball hat that says, lady with a hummingbird.
on top of it. Sam, I hope you are listening and I hope you know that I will absolutely treasure this.
This is such a gift. Thank you so much. Thank you for the clear amount of just artistry and detail
that went into this. There's also a Pam's candy dish. It looks just like her candy dish, but little.
But tiny. And it is so special. I'm going to share pictures in our story. Sam, thank you for taking
the time to make these. I hope our podcast keeps you company as you continue prop making.
Well, lady, we also got an invitation that I know you are going to love. This is from Kim L.
in Mendocino, California. Kim said, hello ladies. If you are fans of Angela Lansbury and
murder she wrote, you might want to come to my hometown. What? I'm not sure if you know this,
but Mendocino hosts the Murder She Wrote Festival.
Wait for it, lady.
Years ago, they used to film here for the outside shots of the fictional town, Cabot Cove,
and now we host the Murder She Wrote Festival.
People come to celebrate the show, and there are so many fun events like trivia games,
a costume contest, and there's a Jessica jog where people dress up in blonde wigs and gray sweatsuits and run through the streets.
Oh, I should say, not only is it a fun weekend, but proceeds from ticket sales, go to support the Kelly House Museum, which is Mendocino's local history nonprofit.
Kim included a flyer. Kim also said this year it's sold out, so put it on your calendar for next spring and come visit. Maybe you could even do a travel journal about it.
Kim, are you kidding me? Look at this flyer. One of the things, if you buy a pass, it says you can participate.
in a salve-along murder she wrote. It's like lady. That's mom detectives happening.
And we could do a travel journal. We could do a whole episode about it.
I want to go. So this year it happened in early May. So let's keep our eye out.
Okay. Kim, thanks for the tip. And finally from Jared B. in Alliance, Ohio. So this one really
cracked me up, okay? Okay. Because I am getting Google alerts, you guys. Not for myself.
I'll continue to share.
Jarrett, I had heard of this, but it tickled me that you wrote in.
So Jarrett says, there is a woman running for Stark County Auditor named Angela Kinsey.
You guys, it's spelled exactly the same way.
Jarrett goes on to say, there's signs all over saying keep Kinsey.
And all I can think of is office ladies, Angela.
Are you secretly running for local office?
I think you'd be a great county auditor.
Wow, I did not know this.
Yeah, so I actually have had a few people say, hey, you might have a doppelkanger in Ohio.
Lady, years ago, I think a woman named Jenna Fisher committed a crime.
Oh, no.
Yeah, and I was getting like alerts.
Oh, my goodness.
Well, thanks, Jarrett, for writing in that tickled me.
And now our office question of the week.
It is from Anna B in Chickchester, UK, if I'm saying that right, Anna.
Anna says, hi, ladies.
I love the podcast.
I listen to you ladies all the time while driving, doing the dishes, falling asleep.
I've tried to get my husband, who's a big office fan, to listen to your podcast, but he can't
merge Angela Martin's cold and snarky attitude with real Angela's fun and upbeat personality.
Oh, no.
My question is, do you have a favorite and least favorite outfit you wore on the show?
Thanks.
Well, my favorite outfit popped into my mind immediately.
Okay.
What about you?
I think my favorite and least favorite happened on the same day.
Oh.
Same episode.
No way.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Mine is from costume contest in season seven.
If you remember, my character dresses as a penguin.
It's so comfortable.
It was like wearing pajamas.
It was cozy.
I wasn't cold.
It was literally amazing.
Then I changed into a nurse, the nurse outfit.
I had this weird push-up bra plus those like cutlet things, you know, that like give you even more cleavage.
And I had like these weird thigh-high stockings and heels that were uncomfortable.
And I was like, this stinks.
I do not like this outfit.
I feel pushed and pulled and cinched and no thank you.
Well, it's very funny to me that your favorite and least favorite were in the same episode,
but also that it was a Halloween episode
because my favorite is from a Halloween episode.
Oh, can I guess?
Is it when you were olive oil?
No.
When I was the kangaroo, when I was super pregnant.
Wait, so basically the penguin and the kangaroo are our favorites.
Similar same.
Yes, exactly.
So comfy.
I was so comfortable.
It was glorious.
It was great.
And it was cute.
It was cute.
cute. You know, I loved everything about it. I thought the penguin was cute. So what was your least
favorite? Guys, I have to be honest. Okay. I really hated that outfit that I wore in Casual
Friday, the matching outfit that I wore with Phyllis that I found on the mannequin. So wait,
it's because it wasn't a jacket, it wasn't a sweater. It was like a shawl or something.
Listen, the shirt was fine.
I didn't mind the shirt.
But it was the weird purple half shawl cardigan thing.
And it just, I think it's like, it's funny.
You know how some things like over time they grow on you?
This is like the opposite of that over time.
Right.
Like every time I see it, it's gotten worse to me.
You're like, that sucks.
Like the first time I approved that costume.
I was like, yeah.
I like it. I believe it. It's good. It's cute. But like it has not aged well. It has aged worse.
You mean a sweater slash jacket weird shawl thing?
Yes. It just was like it wasn't even like a crop. It like came to like the mid brawline. It was yeah.
I'm going to have to shout that out as my least favorite. Well, there you go. Anna B and the United Kingdom. Thank you so much for writing in.
tell your husband to listen to Office Ladies.
Tell him it's okay.
He's going to really like Angela Kinsey.
I hope.
Well, everyone, thank you so much for listening.
And thank you for sending us gifts and sending us your questions.
And a huge thank you to Robin Lynch for joining us today.
Yeah, we hope you guys have a great one.
We'll see you next week.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle, and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.